President Trump is spending the weekend
at his New Jersey Golf Resort after
leaving Washington yesterday on a high
note the Commerce Department reported on
Friday that the gross domestic product
grew at a rate of 4.1% in the second
quarter setting it on course to become
the largest economic growth in over a
decade but the president spent most of
the week on the defensive as new
allegations and an audiotape surfaced of
a meeting he had with his former fixer
Michael Cohen discussing a payout to a
former Playboy model mola Lange he is
traveling with the president in New
Jersey he joins us with the latest mola
good morning
well good morning from New Jersey where
the president is laying low this weekend
at his golf club after a rough few days
that saw the loyalty of Michael Cohen
the president's former fixer and
confidant begin to waver president Trump
is back in Bedminster New Jersey
spending the weekend at his Golf Club
after a rocky week in Washington capped
off by new accusations that he was aware
of a payout to a former Playboy model
and the infamous meeting between
campaign officials and Russians during
the 2016 presidential campaign the
charges come from the president's former
fixer Michael Cohen whose lawyer
released an audio recording in which two
months before the 2016 election mr.
Trump and Cohn discussed paying off
Karen McDougal with whom mr. Trump
allegedly had an affair Cohen also
claims that his former boss knew in
advance of the June 2016 Trump Tower
meeting that included Donald Trump jr.
and a group of Russians to discuss dirt
on Hillary Clinton something he and his
associates have consistently denied
president Trump doubled down on Friday
tweeting in part I did not know of the
meeting with my son Don Junior Cohen is
currently under federal investigation
for his personal business dealings the
president's attorney Rudy Giuliani who
just two months ago praised Cohen as an
honest honorable lawyer now calls
Cohen's claim a lie I expected something
like this from Cummings been lying all
week I mean or for two entire four years
on Friday President Trump was able to
tout some good
economic news in the second quarter of
this year the United States economy grew
at the amazing rate of 4.1% but Cohen
shadow continues to loom over the
president the president is scheduled to
return to the White House tomorrow he'll
likely face some tough questions from
the press on Monday tough questions
he'll likely be unable to avoid when he
holds a press conference with the
visiting Italian prime minister on
Monday Anthony mola leggy with the
president in New Jersey thanks mullah